ATISSA BANUAZIZI: the feedback
that we give them really
involves encouraging
them to show them
how they can use the core
material on their slides,
but also their
metadiscourse in presenting,
and that's sort of
like a term that we
use to explain like
how you talk about what
you're talking about.
And so the
metadiscourse is often
what does the best job of making
those links for the benefit
of the audience.
And ultimately, a lot of the
feedback that we offer to them
has to do with getting them
to think about the audience
and who they are and helping
them understand, because this
isn't something that
they necessarily
come in understanding, that they
need to speak and write in such
a way that it can be understood
not only by the professor who
obviously knows
more than they do,
but by somebody who isn't
familiar with the experiment,
who's coming to it
for the first time.